deux chirurgiens dentistes comparaissait
ce matin devant la 14e chambre
correctionnelle de paris en signe de
protestation la fédération des
chirurgiens dentistes de l'île de france
avait demandé à ses adhérents de fermer
leur cabinet toute la matinée les deux
prévenus étaient accusés de brutalité à
l'encontre d'un inspecteur de la
sécurité sociale les deux dentistes nie
les faits un nouvel incident qui
s'inscrit dans le contentieux qui oppose
depuis quelques temps déjà dans notre
région
les chirurgiens dentistes et la sécurité
sociale deux philosophies de la santé
s'oppose à l'occasion de ce conflit
d'un côté la sécurité sociale ont le
taux de remboursement des honoraires et
des matériels utilisés en fonction d'une
nomenclature vieille de 19 ans de
l'autre côté les dentistes qui suivent
les progrès techniques en matière de
soins et de matériel ne vois pas
pourquoi la sécurité sociale ne veut pas
prendre en compte les frais de cette
évolution pour remplacer une dent 10 et
dentistes pourquoi la sécurité sociale
rembourse hôtel une dent à pivot alors
que plus personne ne veut de cet
assemblage de ferraille et les matières
plastiques
pourquoi fondé le remboursement des
prothèses en fonction d'appareil
dépasser sans cesse à refaire et refuser
le remboursement d'un bridge définitif
est de meilleure qualité pour les
dentistes
tout se passe comme si la sécurité
sociale voulait encourager une médecine
ancienne et au rabais et décourager les
efforts de recyclage de ceux qui ne
veulent plus être des arracheurs de
dents